you have one of the most distinct voices
and manners of anyone in show business
and that's a gift there's a lot of
people that do impressions of you yes
yes I know I know I know and I like them
all do you do it well you have you've
done it for me I don't really do a form
impression I just notice it tuna mean
there's a lot of I need your glasses
session very good and so that's the part
I like little noses you made perfect
what is that what are the noises you
make I'm humming it's a hum you know put
your lips together yeah um-hmm I got the
one from you you do that Bob Hope
you just noticing that he's
subconsciously removing his wedding ring
while he's doing this yes well I like to
play with it I like to play with it
that's true
I like to play with I'm wearing jewelry
and I should tactile II get oriented as
I am I should have nothing that's what I
like I wash my hands I like I'd like
nothing I like to move my hands in right
but you're like a lizard yeah a lizard
really just because my movements are you
mean my ring well just no no not the
rings there but just I am that you
weren't wearing quite a bit of jewelry I
know to do I know I know what are you
doing with those I don't know I just
love them I just think fantastic I just
love these are these are just really
good these are these are statement
glasses these lights goes well I guess I
like them I like them very much
they're new I don't think you've seen
these no no it's kind of vintage II you
notice that you notice these two hinges
there sure really notice things that but
yes okay two hinges yes you notice
everything okay so do i I'm telling you
Andy this he's a very sensual man he is
it yet I'm always his sensuality when
I'm around you mean now look he's
stroking the furniture
look at this well these are new chairs I
believe yeah we have a whole new set
yeah it's very beautiful
yeah yeah very beautiful okay well and
how about these those are flowers and
they're real
yeah oh they're flowers I thought for a
second they were fake I'm very impressed
those are wonderful
you